ELIZABETH WU: Today we're
presenting on real time
streaming applications on GCP.
So I'm going to present with
my colleague, Akhilesh Singh.
So we're both from Syndey
from the J/APAC Professional
Services team.
And Akhilesh is the lead
strategic cloud engineer.
And I'm a cloud consultant
in data analytics.
So we work on this
stuff every day.
So hopefully we'll
share a little bit
of what we've learned with you.
So there's three things
we're going to cover.
The first is, why Google Cloud?
Then, I'll talk
about what we have
to offer on Google Cloud and the
different suites of products--
like the different products that
are available to do streaming
real time applications.
And then I'll go through
how you would do it.
And then after that
we've got a demo
and there's a chance to win-- we
have some free prizes so we're
going to get some interactivity
going, and at that point
I'm going to ask you to
pull out your phones.
So if everyone wants to get
your internet connection ready,
that would be good.
So let's start with why.
Big data is in
our DNA at Google.
We have over eight products--
so we have eight products
with over 1 billion users.
A lot of the products that we're
making available through to you
to do these types of problems--
to solve these problems,
are things that
we use internally
and that we have made
available to the community.
So this was started
in 2002, where
we've been innovating on
lots of different products.
So you might have heard
of Bigtable or Spanner.
And a lot of these
innovations were
made available to the
open source community.
And so what we're now doing
is then bringing those back
to Google Cloud
Platform and making
them available as services--
as managed services to you.
Things like BigQuery
and Pub/Sub and Bigtable
are all services
that we provide.
So our focus for the customer
is to focus on insights.
So rather than you having to
worry about the infrastructure,
letting you focus on what
you want to do with the data
and get the insights
out is our key focus.
Another is looking at
streaming analytics.
So being able to get real
time business insights
and make your business
more responsive.
So if you can get
insights in real time,
then you can also
react in real time.
And then we make that easier
to do using machine learning.
So what you can
do is, once you've
got your data
coming in real time,
apply our machine learning
algorithm on top of that
and actually make it
actionable automatically
without you having to
manually intervene.
So I'll talk about what next.
So what's available on
Google Cloud Platform
to do streaming analytics
and streaming apps.
So we focus on four
stages of a data platform.
So the first is the ability
to ingest at any scale.
So what we're going
to show you today
is actually not that
we can do streaming,
but that we can do it at scale.
So we're going to
have the ability
to ingest thousands of
millions of messages.
The second is to process and
transform the data reliably.
The third is to
store seamlessly.
And the fourth is to analyze,
learn, visualize, with speed.
So we're going to go
through each one of these
and I'm going to talk through
all the Google Cloud Platform
products that enable
each of these.
So that brings me to the how.
This is a typical data pipeline
that I going to walk through.
And we have lots of different
ways of doing things,
so this is just, sort of, one
way of piecing things together,
but it's quite a
common architecture.
So we start with
streaming events coming in
from IoT devices,
or in this case
we're actually going to have
mobile device data that's
coming in and that will be
written to a Cloud Pub/Sub
topic.
And we can read from that
Cloud Pub/Sub topic as well.
So Cloud Pub/Sub as is a
serverless, fully managed
asynchronous messaging platform.
So basically it's
pretty straightforward.
You just publish a
topic and read from it.
The second is, we can
also ingest batch data.
So you can actually do both
of those at the same time.
So Dataflow, which is
going to be the next step,
is going to be able to handle
both those types of streams
of data sources.
And that is going to be read
into Cloud Storage, which
is our performant, unified and
cost-effective object storage
bucket for binary blob data.
So then it's going to
go into Cloud Dataflow.
So Dataflow has connectors to
Pub/Sub and to Cloud Storage.
And it's going to be
able to process our data
and apply transformations as we
need them to batch your stream.
So one interesting
thing about Dataflow
is that we can handle
real time streaming data.
So we can apply things--
something you do
differently to batch data
is you apply things like
windowing functions, where
you take an aggregate of the
data that's being read in
and you pass that downstream.
But we can also use all
the products like Dataproc.
So, if you have already
got Spark and Hadoop jobs,
you can migrate them
over to Dataproc.
And we can then, from
Dataflow, write it out
to be BigQuery or Bigtable.
So it can go to lots
of different sources,
this is just an example.
So BigQuery is our Data
Warehousing solution
and Bigtable is our
high performance NoSQL
database for large workloads.
And then we can apply machine
learning on top of that.
So once the data is in the
database, we can pull it out
or we can actually use it
directly from Dataflow.
And then we have a lot
of visualization options
and different analytical tools.
So we can use Cloud
Datalab law which
is was a Jupyter notebooks
type of environment.
You can use either third
party tools or something
like Data Studio, which
is a Bi tool that we have.
You can share with
other people or you can
produce applications reports.
So we've done the last
one today as well,
so we can show you that.
OK, so we're about ready
to start the competition.
So can I ask everyone if
you want to participate,
get your phones out right now
and get a web browser open.
And we're going to give
you a URL in a minute,
so you would get that ready.
These are the prizes,
just to give you
a little bit of an incentive.
So we have a pair of Google
Cloud socks, a beanie,
and a t-shirt.
So what we're going to do
is, you're going to vote
and the highest score will
win one of these prizes.
Over to you, Akhilesh.
AKHILESH SINGH: So this is
the URL we need to go to.
And you will see a very
simple voting application
with military logos.
You can't go wrong there.
Just into your username
and you start voting.
So, if everything
goes well, you'll
see your name happening here.
ELIZABETH WU: Akhilesh--
Akhilesh.
Probably just leave URL
a little bit longer.
AKHILESH SINGH: Sure.
ELIZABETH WU: Yeah.
OK, so we're going
to start a timer
and we'll bring the URL back
up and you'll have one minute.
So go back to the
URL page, Akhilesh.
Can you bring up the URL?
Yep.
So it is bit.ly/2WRivbP
and the "ivb" is lowercase.
Try and vote as many
times as you can
when launching the products.
You might want to pick
one that you really
like with the socks or
the heart and the beanie
and then in about a
minute we'll wind down.
Can you get the
timer up Akhilesh?
Cool.
So Akhilesh, while
it's going do you
mind explaining what's
happening in the back end?
AKHILESH SINGH:
Yeah, so in reak time
when you're pressing
a button, the request
is going to App Engine instance.
And App Engine
scales automatically,
you don't have to scale it.
We were actually not
running in instances.
But because of the
voting application,
we'll see that there will
be many instances which
be recreated on the fly.
On the other side
of things, there's
Dataflow which
lists out the vote.
And in Dataflow
flow what happens
is like, when the messages
out in the pops up queue,
it reads from that.
And as you can see
it's processing
huge number of messages
without any scaling.
Was that the results that
actually presented here?
So you can see like the
Rangers winning as of now
for Sox and with a
total of 15 votes.
And this is updating
in real time
as you click on
the buttons, right?
ELIZABETH WU: Oh,
how much time left?
Are we nearly done?
AKHILESH SINGH: Yeah.
14 seconds away.
ELIZABETH WU: Oh, well 10--
10 seconds 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Akhilesh take a screenshot.
AKHILESH SINGH: Yeah.
ELIZABETH WU: So whoever
is listed at the top
now after the session,
please come over
to the experiment pod 1 and
we'll give you your prize.
AKHILESH SINGH: Yes, so we'll
take a second to just let it
refresh and we
declare the winners.
Good.
So this is not the end of it.
Like, when you build
a really cool app
it may actually become very
popular across the globe.
And not only 100, but
let's say like there
are millions of users.
So I'm using a tool
which is, JMeter,
it's a bare bones JMeter
which can create millions
of requests on our server.
And we start seeing that
we are encountering 0% data
and the number of
requests is this.
So there's already
3,000 requests
which has been passed in
a short duration of time.
And let's see if it
reflects on the--
that's what--
So as you see this is completely
a serverless solution.
It relies on components
which Liz talked about,
this App Engine,
and this Dataflow.
This scale all available without
any developer intervention.
Liz, up to you.
ELIZABETH WU: Back
to the slides.
Cool, so I'm just going to
talk through what we just
did, just to recap.
So can you skip--
sorry, I'll do it.
So what we did was we
read real-time events
in from your mobile devices
using an App Engine front end.
So that's actually scaling
up to meet the demand.
So however many people
here who have us
logging on at this
time, we're scaling up,
and then Akhilesh
just showed you
that last screen,
when he was doing
was injecting a lot of
extra events from a robot.
And then that's being read
in through Cloud Pub/Sub.
So it's been
published to a topic
and we're reading that back
through from Cloud Dataflow.
So Cloud Dataflow is
taking those messages
and processing them in
Parallel, in real-time,
with latency of just
a couple of seconds,
and publish them to BigQuery.
And from BigQuery, we're
representing that dashboard
on the screen, which is
showing you the leaderboard.
So we've managed to piece
it together end to end.
And then we can also
do a few more things
which we didn't during
this presentation,
but it's just to demonstrate
as well that you can actually
get batch data and
at the same time.
And you can actually process
both batches of streaming data
together with Cloud Dataflow,
or separately if you wish,
and then output it to
lots of different options
of destinations.
So just to recap, there's
a couple of big customers
that are using
solutions like this.
We have Twitter, who's
using it to help them scale.
So they've got a hybrid
Hadoop and Dataproc cluster
and they're working towards a
fully serverless environment
on Google Cloud.
We have AirAsia with
500 million passengers.
They're using BigQuery,
Pub/Sub, Data Studio.
And they've been able to reduce
their costs using those tools.
And we have Spotify
who are Cloud Native
and have implemented these
solutions to help them.
So the key takeaway
today is that the focus
is on real-time insights.
So we have these massive
amounts of data coming in
and we want to be able to
make use of them in real time,
make decisions in real time,
and add value to your business
in real time.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]